Stanford I always uh include that I'm a
PhD student on leave and actually last
time I spoke in my advisor seminar um
just a few weeks ago he said oh I
learned something already that Larry's
still a student so uh anyway it's always
a pleasure to be back at Stanford and uh
let me get started
so actually at some point my computer
will wake up in advance okay so what am
I going to talk about I was trying to
build a talk that's really focused on
entrepreneurs it looks like a lot of you
guys might be entrepreneurs or want to
be entrepreneurs and uh I'm going to try
to be a little bit controversal and you
should feel free to stop me and ask
questions or uh uh refute the points I'm
making uh so maybe I'll argue things a
little more strongly than they should be
just to make a point um but I think
there's a lot of opportunity out in the
world by doing things a bit differently
than other companies have done them and
I'm sort of amazed more people don't do
this and I'm going to use Google as an
example of a way of doing things
differently
um and uh then I'm going to talk briefly
I try to cover some things about
entrepreneurship that I think aren't
covered other places so I'm going to
assume you guys have all read lots of
books and Heard lots of great talks
today and other times about General
things about entrepreneurship and I'll
try to cover the things that I think
people don't know or are less
represented and I'll try to explain a
little bit about how we do these things
at
Google so this is actually a picture of
me at a pretty young age playing with
Legos um
and I've always you know I just wanted
to give you a brief background about
myself so you kind of know where I'm
coming from I usually don't do this in
talks but I think it will help you
understand um the points I'm trying to
make so I had a computer I was lucky
enough to have a computer in my house at
H6 um because my father was a computer
science professor and this a pretty
unusual thing um this was
1978 um it's a pretty unusual time to
have a computer and I think I was the
first kid in my elementary school to
turn in a word processed assignment
which kind of amazed my teachers um and
at a pretty young age I wanted to be an
inventor and actually I read a um
autobiography of Tesla and I read all
about Tesla and Tesla is the guy who
invented AC power and generators and all
sorts of things that we use today and he
barely was able to support his work uh
you he's probably one of the greatest
inventors of all time and he's sort of
pathetic in that you know he would have
been able to do more if he was better at
commercializing his inventions and so I
realized soon after reading this
autobiography that um what I should
really do is start company or be a
professor someplace that I could have a
lot of influence on what happens in the
world because my goal is really to
change the world by bringing new things
into it um I think this background sort
of helped me you know even though I have
a very technical background I knew I'd
probably want to start a company at some
point so I did a lot of work in that
area um so uh eventually ended up at
Stanford the PHD program we started the
research actually I guess you already
mentioned most of this intro um we
actually ranged an angel raised an angel
Fund in 1998 if people have questions I
could talk about that more but it was
pretty straightforward process it still
took several months but um there was a
lot of people who wanted to invest and
it took us time because you know you
want to do these things right and one of
our original Angels Ram shiram is still
on our board and still very helpful to
the company so it's important to get the
right people involved and sometimes you
know that would probably always take
time um we raised the VC round in May 99
um we have John dor from Kleiner um it's
one of the main VCS in the valley and
also Mike Moritz from sequa who a
invested in yahu and bunch of other
companies uh it was unusual for us to
get both of those
guys um so now we're profitable we have
over 300 employees we have about 50 phds
which is kind of unusual uh we have
offices all around the
world so that's the basic background I
want to give you let me talk about um
I'll start off sort of saying uh I think
there's a common fallacy especially in
Business Schools so I thought I'd bring
this up being in the business school
today um that products aren't that
important or technology isn't that
important and there's a couple common
examples people give one is VHS versus
beta you guys familiar with this example
you know beta was the better technology
in
vhs1 um and uh in fact you know the
Technologies aren't that different and
you know people are probably mostly
concerned with price and you know
avability and things like that so you
know it's not a very good example same
thing for Microsoft versus Apple
Microsoft really had more distribution
they're more open in the way they did
their distribution and I'd argue you
know the products for a while there's
differentiation in products but there
certainly isn't that much right now um
and so that's also not a good example I
think in the Enterprise space Also you
know people think technology isn't
important in the Enterprise space
because it's not basically um you know
how complicated is it to build a system
that you you know keeps track of your
finances I mean it's just not a
particularly hard technical problem it's
mostly business problem right how you
know who does watch in the business how
you manage them how you control your
spending and all those kinds of
things um I think Google's a pretty good
example of why you know products
technology are important so and I'll
talk more about that so you know the
common wisdom is that you know marketing
is what really matters you know based on
this products technology not mattering
and I think that sort of Misses one key
thing which is the internet and the
internet is changing the world and if
you look at the trend which the internet
represents you'll say you know with the
internet you'll probably have better
information than you do now on products
um you know if you assume people have
pretty good information on products are
they going to buy the right product
probably and they'll probably use that
information rather than your advertising
range um you also gives you distribution
with the internet you can have a lot of
distribution without spending very much
money and um I'll give you some examples
of that and I'd also argue you know
people have choice would they really
want to watch the same TV at a 100 times
you know if you have a too you know
you're going to fast forward right and
there's actually legislation to prevent
you from fast forwarding that's in the
works right now but I assume probably
you know given enough choice and uh you
know reasonably uh well formed
government that um will end up with
choice in these
things um I think the other thing people
are missing is that products can be
improved a lot um it's not the case that
most things work and excuse me uh I was
just actually um at the Ted conference
which was in monter and uh there's Walt
Mossberg there gave a talk he's kind of
a Wall Street Journal technology um he
has Wall Street Journal technology
column where he basically complains
about everything and you know it's been
tremendously popular column in the Wall
Street Journal because basically says
you know why don't any of these things
work um and I'll have a quote from him
later but uh you know things can be much
much better than they are
now finally not everything's toothpaste
there's probably not that much
difference between toothpaste you know
mostly works and so on so you know
that's where on those kind of products
you see a lot of marketing right so
there's not much else you can
do so I'd argue that most companies are
actually innovating only in business
space not in technology at all and I
think there's a bunch of reasons for
that in the industry I don't think it's
because there's not huge opportunity in
technology it's because that requires a
broad understanding of sort of the
business the technical side you might
need to know about hardware and software
Google you know we're mostly perceived
as an internet company but part of our
Innovation was having lowcost Hardware
um which we basically you know you can
see in the Gates Building there's a disc
case we manufactured and we continue to
you know buy our computers significantly
cheaper than anyone else does which
helped us because we have uh about
15,000
computers um and so part of that is you
know the lowcost hardware made the
software po
possible um so do interesting things you
know you have to do pretty broad you
have to have pretty broad understanding
um there aren't very many good examples
of this I mean I don't think there are
that many companies that have really
succeeded because they had great
technology I'd argue Google is a pretty
good example um there aren't that many
examples
um so I have this great quote from a
search engine which is now actually out
of business um from a CEO of search
engine which was I guess about 1997 he
said this um when they're just sort of
becoming a portal he said our search
engines 80% as good as the other guys
and in fact he said you know we've done
focus groups and we uh we've done all
this research and we don't think it
searches you know the quality of search
matters uh because people can't tell the
difference and um this didn't really
Inspire us to want to work for him and
the um and at the time we were we wanted
to license technology to this company um
it didn't end up working out um this is
one of the reasons uh but it's
interesting because the leaders of these
companies didn't understand that search
technology would improve uh they thought
search was you know done you know they
should move on to other things like
horoscopes or whatever and uh you know
search would be something they all had
and it would be roughly similar and I'll
just give you some numbers so since 1998
when we started we had about 30 million
web pages in our index and that was
competitive now we're by far the largest
we have over three billion items you
know three years later and you know that
doesn't just sort of happen
spontaneously right that's a lot of work
and you have to put serious money into
development to get those kinds of things
to happen
um so having this Vision about where
things are going to go is really
important
um and in fact you know we grew with
virtually no advertising and uh uh in
about three years you know we become
largest search provider on the internet
um um and that's basically because we
have a product that people want hey all
you guys on the back do you want to fill
in down the front there's lots of seats
why don't we break and how people you
guys look really
uncomfortable yeah come on don't be
shy you're welcome so I'll just keep
talking as you guys file in um why isn't
there very much product Innovation and I
think this can help you guys as Entre r
preneurs or is thinking about how you
can make an impact in the world you say
how how can we have innovation in the
world um you know why aren't all these
big companies doing the right thing
and I guess I found even at Google when
you start to have large teams working on
anything you get above about 10 people
it's really hard to be Innovative it's
hard to do things differently um and
actually if you have sales involved in
the process you know sales tends to want
to actually you to build exactly what
your competitors have because that's
what the customers are asking for um and
we actually just released an Enterprise
Appliance and this is a real issue for
that we released a box that's designed
to go into Enterprises and it's
different than what everybody else sells
and if you ask the customers they'll say
oh you know we want all these features
they won't actually tell you they want
something that works and it's low cost
and those kinds of things because they
don't even really realize that's
possible um so this is a big issue for
companies um leaders are usually not
technical or even product focused
they're not sort of focused on whether
something will work for people and um
actually uh a lot of people would argue
companies always become marketing or
sales
driv another thing that happens is
companies grow we have about 300 people
and we do basically a couple of things
and when we were about three people we
did one thing and so right now we went
from having about three people working
on you know Google or you know that size
business to having you know
100 people working on the equivalent
sized business and so it's harder to
change when you have 100 people working
on something you can also do more but
it's also harder to change so if you're
an entrepreneur you can use this to your
advantage um you know big companies are
going to be slower to move they're going
to it's going to be hard for them to add
businesses it's going to be hard for
them to do things that aren't sales
driven so if you can really innovate in
a space um because you have some Vision
about it that can be really
helpful
another point I want to make about
advertising just because it was fun um
so when we were we were thinking about
uh uh marketing Google in the early days
we actually had some marketing people
who wanted us to spend like $5 million
on a TV
campaign and you sort of asked them well
why do you want to do that and they say
well that's what you're supposed to do
to get people to learn about your
product and I say well why don't and
they say we should spend you know 30% of
that online and 70% offline on TV I said
we the 7030 come from and you know this
sort of becomes a well that's just what
people do kind of argument um you should
always be suspicious when you get even
numbers for anything
um and in fact um I had this later
explained to me by a CEO who works um
just recently who works uh he runs a
very large advertising company he said
the reason is that all the VPS of
marketing companies life goal life dream
is to to uh do the Apple Super Bowl app
you guys all laugh but it's actually
kind of true if you talk to these people
you know they're really they really like
art and they you know it's an exciting
thing to do and you can have a big
impact on the world so you know that's a
really exciting thing you know to build
a Super Bowl ad that everyone will
remember and will affect the whole
computer industry right like apples did
um that's pretty unlikely though and
it's maybe not the right way to spend
money right um You have to make an
analogy you have similar kind of thing
in product marketing the kind of people
who Define products and companies
traditionally um have some business
background or they have sort of pretty
random background besides the business
background and they're not really
focused on products and there's some
good programs here at Stanford you know
we're really lucky to have the HDI
program and other product design kinds
of things and mechanical engineering
traditionally people who design products
don't have that background and that
argue it really
shows
um so I'd argue in companies a technical
company this whole talks focused to
technical entrepreneurship not other
things obviously in a technical company
you really need to have technical
leadership or at least leadership to who
somewhat understands that and in fact we
just um we hired a CEO about six months
ago uh who's Eric Schmidt who was CEO of
Novel and he's sort of unique in being
CEO of a large tech company and having a
PhD in computer science and before he
was a novel he was CTO of sun um that's
pretty unusual background I mean I think
there's proba probably only a handful of
people who have experiened being CEO of
a major tech company and um have a deep
technical background and for Google
that's particularly important but I
think it's more important in the
industry than people uh would generally
believe
um uh so Walt mberg um yesterday I saw
him talk and he made this great point I
just had to to bring to you guys was
that um when you buy a computer and it
doesn't work you know you start writing
to your colist and you ask them what you
should do and you go on you know message
boards and you talk to your friends and
you try to fix it right and he was
making the analogy well if what if you
bought a TV that didn't work didn't get
channel six or something you know would
you roll up your sleeves and take it
apart and try to fix it no I mean you
don't have that expectation about
televisions and so people have this very
funny expectation about computers that
it's okay if they don't work and I think
this comes from the hobbyist background
you know computers started with
hobbyists who have had to write their
own software or you know do all sorts of
crazy things but nowadays you know
computers and software should just work
and there's really no excuse why it
doesn't so okay I'm almost done with
this part um finally um there's
something I like to call the technology
Trend bandwagon and so I threw up a
bunch of words up there xml. net
cora2 anyway all of these things I think
basically don't do
anything um
and I you know I would hesitate to
speculate how much money has been spent
on
them uh so I think you need to be really
careful the industry gets really excited
about something and companies promote it
and the reporters don't necessarily the
the journalists don't understand the
technology and so you get these whole
big uh waves that go through the
industry that don't really do very much
um like for example we actually don't
use any scuzzy discs even though scuzzi
are sort of supposedly high performance
things we use ID because it's
cheaper and this is like you know a lot
of technical people would say you know
you guys are crazy it's like almost a
religious War like you know Macintosh
versus Windows or something but it
doesn't really matter you know it's just
how much money it costs um I want to
give a few more examples of this um uh
when you go to fries and you buy a
flatbed scanner how many of you guys
have a flatbed scanner raise your hands
okay a fair number of people when you go
there every month you go to fries you
know they'll doubled the resolution so
you know they started out 300 DPI which
is like roughly a fax machine and now
they're up to 1,200 or 2400 DPI which
like lets you digitize each piece of Ink
on the paper a little dot of ink which
you can't even see with your naked eye
it's not tremendously useful for most
things um the only reason You' need
resolution like that is to scan slides
which isn't that common a task and in
fact uh you'd probably much rather have
a scanner that was fast um you know most
scanners take like a minute to scan a
page which is a really long time right
but they don't advertise how long they
take because they take so long you
wouldn't buy one if they print it on the
box um so is there there's probably a
lot of uh opportunity to build a scanner
that's fast right because nobody else is
doing that um but the whole industry is
on this resolution kick rather than
doing the things that people would
really need which is actually you know
to be able to get they worked on in a
reasonable amount of time
right um let's see um same thing with
still cameras uh you know still cameras
digital cameras are going up in
resolution the video cameras
aren't um there's no particularly good
reason for that either right you
probably make a lot of money selling a
video camera that had higher resolution
so it would produce you know spectacular
things right um uh anyway a bunch of
other things the question you should ask
is really um do users really care about
what what is the the company is doing or
what it is that's going on and or you
know does it help Engineers um that's
also a legitimate thing but most of
these things uh you know I'd say no for
all of these
right so you can start off uh one one
characteristic you know in saying all of
this I'll give you I guess some
entrepreneurial advice is that uh people
like to argue with you and you have to
be pretty strong and my co-founder
Sergey I guess known for being kind of a
obnoxious and uh uh uh pretty strongly
opinionated um in fact I think one of
our early VCS I won't mention which ones
that we talked to we almost came to
blows with um which wasn't a good
situation I don't recommend this but
um there's something to be said for
having um strong opinions as long as you
know what you're talking about and uh I
think that's really important uh it's
fine to have opinions that aren't
conventional like you know we do TV
advertising it's going to cost too much
um as long as you know you have math to
back that up or a good argument right um
and I want to give one more example when
we started running advertising on Google
we started with text based ads and um
all of our sales people all the people
in the industry said you guys are crazy
you should be running banner ads and we
said no you know you want text based ads
because you know most of the time people
click on the search results and if you
present ads that you know have you know
what people want
just like the search results they'll
click on them most of the time and in
fact you know the search results get
like a 50% clickr or something right
half the time people click on the search
result and you know average ads get you
know a tenth of 1% click through so
you've got a factor of 300 in Click
through right between the ads and the
search results and the search results
are text right so this argument you know
as long as you have a good argument
about these things and you really stick
to it um you know that can work but I
won't tell you how many people in the
company argued with me on this point you
know really violently and it almost
didn't happen as and actually it's been
a very good business for us and as a
result we're profitable um and from
other
sources um so this isn't a picture of
tusla who I mentioned earlier but it's
somebody these are the kinds of things
that Tesla would do um for fun uh and I
already covered these points but I did
want to say you know you can have a lot
of great ideas but um entrepreneurship
is really about proration I mean you
have to do a lot of work it's not an
easy thing to do um and there's a lot of
great ideas in the world you know um you
really need to make them happen and
that's the that's the
work so I'm going to go through this
really fast this is from another talk I
gave um but the idea is I just wanted to
show maybe for the more engineering
minded kinds of people the kinds of
things that I think about and the ways
you can identify maybe areas that would
be good opportunities for entrepreneurs
worship and the basic idea is the last
point I make which is you want to find
things that seem wrong and I know this
sounds very negative like you walk
around the world getting upset about
things um but actually that turns out to
be important you know you should you
should notice when um you have trouble
coming in the door because the handles
designed wrong um Don Norman who has a
great book on this you know explains in
great detail all the poorly designed
door handles you're just like this guy
is crazy but after you read this book
you walk around the world and you get
upset when you when you uh I guess that
could be depressing too um but it turns
out to be really useful because you walk
around the world and you notice things
that are designed wrong and you know
those things are all great opportunities
for improvement maybe not door handles
but other
things um so I want just go through this
I want to give some examples of things
people aren't good at keeping track of
and um one thing that I was really
astounded by is I computed this couple a
couple weeks ago was the uh cost of a
computer is actually down to about
$200 like a pretty decent computer um
and you know you kind of wonder why
people spend $1,000 on their computer in
fact somebody my family just bought a
computer and they spent like
$2,000 and they got a computer that's
sort of marginally better than this one
um but anyway it's good to keep track of
cost of things because that's really
what drives adoption um you look at
something like 802.11 which is the
wireless networking oh it's dropped in
price tremendously and in fact it's down
to about $60 right you sort of think
about well if I have $60 for a
high-speed wireless network you know
that operates over a couple hundred feet
you know maybe I'm going to start to put
that everywhere because you know it
costs less than doing the wiring right
but the price is really really important
and you also notice notebooks are way
more expensive than desktop machines
which is also not probably commonly
known so I think there's about 10 failed
companies based on this slide which is
that uh the minimum cost of an LCD for a
PC is about $300
a pretty small LCD like you'd find in
your laptop and you know a monitor you
can get a pretty good monitor for like
uh you know
$120 you know people people in the real
world sort of care about costs and so
are you going to be able to build an
appliance you know that goes in your
kitchen that costs you know hundreds of
dollars more just because it has an LCD
well there's a bunch of failed companies
based on that premise you know I think
purely due to the
cost um storage I just wanted to
highlight one thing here too um if you
have tape media you know it's almost the
same price as hard diss a dollar per
gigabyte and tape is like a lot harder
to deal with than discs um do you think
tape is a great you know business to be
in probably not right eventually all the
you'll get all replaced with discs in
fact we're doing that at Google we don't
really use any tape we use a very small
amount of tape um we have about uh a
th000 terabytes of
dis um and almost no tape so anyway um
one other point I want to make is
there's a whole bunch of companies in
the valley that are based on disk and I
would give you companies like Oracle as
examples um their technology
fundamentally is operating on Diss and
if you notice the last point on the
slide dis is actually about 200,000
times slower than
memory um at doing a random access and
you know it turns out that memory is
actually Ram is cheap enough now that
you can put basically any database you
want in
memory and you know it's probably a lot
EAS for programmers to deal with
something that's 200,000 times faster
right and it doesn't cost particularly
more um so the industry is very slow to
notice these things I mean are there
great opportunities in all of these
numbers certainly there's great
opportunities for companies and all of
these things you just need to keep track
of them um I just going to show you how
much memory how much power things use
they you know discs use like five Watts
or something um go to this slide uh if
you want want to power your disc for a
while you know you need like you know a
pound of batteries is basically how it
works out and this is why laptops don't
really have battery life is because
basically the amount of power in a
battery isn't very much compared to
things like processors which can use as
much as 100 Watts so 100 watts of
battery you know for an hour is like a
big thing right if you have even the
best possible battery which is basically
lithium ion you're still going to have
like two pounds of battery just to power
that for an hour which is clearly a
problem if you're carrying it around
um so this also isn't that relevant to
you guys but I just thought I'd show it
um because I saw at the Ted conference
yesterday was really exciting um kind of
basic technology thing um and I thought
I'd show this to you because I think if
you base companies on things like this
you know you can find a good business I
don't think robotics necessarily a great
business um but if you find someplace
where there's a good business
opportunity and sort of a technological
breakthrough then you're you're in a
really strong business position relative
to just having a business opportunity or
just having a technological opportunity
and um I thought I'd show this just
because it's really really cool so
there's this guy Robert pH who's
Professor Berkeley who's been studying
uh Locomotion in insects basically in
small animals and it's pretty amazing
stuff he basically they figured out that
cockroaches and things like that can go
through if you look on the right hand
side here they can go through this kind
of very rough terrain without even
slowing down at
all like they just go full speed through
you know terrain that's like higher than
they are and you know they're trying to
figure out how they could possibly do
this and you know you think the
cockroaches have really sophisticated
control mechanism things like that well
they actually decided that it's because
the cockroach's legs are
springy and um this recent research they
just did and so they decided Well maybe
we should try to build a robot based on
this and see how well it works and it
turns out I'll show you this little
animation here I downloaded from their
website so this is this robot um that
has no control system those are just
Motors that are spinning and this is
like an order of magnitude better than
all of the robots that have
existed and the reason is the legs are
springy and so the legs basically do the
control automatically mechanically
rather than using
Electronics um I'll show you they did
some other fun things with this
robot um that's just altering the timing
of the way the motors are spinning you
got that behavior here's the robot going
through the I don't have the Cockroach
picture you can see this robot also goes
fine through this fractal terrain it's
called um so anyway if you building
robots you know having having um this
technology would be a real help right
you'd probably be able to compete really
well against the people who are building
wheel robots or much more complicated
things um in fact they even have they
even put this in a lake and it can swim
and it goes right out of the lake onto
land and it's pretty incredible um so
there's a lot of things like this in the
world I mean it's not necessarily Lots
but there's enough to start companies
based on and if you start a company on
one of these things you I'd argue you're
likely to be a lot more successful than
if you're just uh using
business um so I'm going to segue into
some entrepreneurship things these are
basically things that um I found people
are sort of under investing in and I
want to give some examples from the
conference again I was just ask they're
really fresh in my mind um do you guys
know who Dean Cayman is he's the guy
with the segue the it the scooter you
know what I'm talking about this like
really fancy scooter and you kind of
think he's crazy if you see the you know
if you read the pr about him he has this
scooter that cost $30,000 and it's like
why would you want that right and it
it's very cool technologically and all
these things and it may or may not be
successful as a business but Dean is an
amazing guy because he the reason he's
building these scooters is that he
thinks cities aren't going to work and
he gave a great talk where he talked
about you know all the people in China
that are going into cities and I think
it's like 500 million people um even in
the next five years or 10 years
something like that and if you compute
if they all you know had reasonable
number of cars they would actually use
more gas than is available and this is a
problem right you know this is happening
and there's not a good technological
solution and he really feels strongly
that you need uh you know more
environmentally conscious more istic
ways of doing transportation in cities
if he fails you know with his scooter
I'm sure he'll do something else you
know that's even more cool right so he's
going to succeed because he has a real
Vision he's going to solve in a problem
that's very important in the world he's
very very dedicated to it right and you
know that can really uh help your
Venture if you have a really deeply held
belief you're not just trying to make
money you know you want to change the
world or you want to solve a problem you
think it's a really serious problem uh
that can really give you a lot of
Leverage it makes other people believe
in you it gets you resources um it just
does tremendously good things he also
has a similar belief that people should
be focused on science and not Sports and
he has I think like 10,000 kids now par
participating in His science program
where they build robots it's an amazing
thing it's been growing tremendously
fast um and again because he has a
really deeply held belief around
that um Amry lovens also has a similar
kind of thing where he believes uh
inefficient and restorative use of
resources he's done all sorts of amazing
things like he built a house in Aspen
that's heated only by a banana farm and
it's completely livable inside and it
costs less to build than an equivalent
house with a heating
system um and he's building you know 100
m hour car gallon car that's not worse
than an existing car in any way it's
just
lighter um so anyway I think having a
strong Vision strong goal for what
you're going to do can really help you
be successful uh in your
businesses um I'd argue Microsoft school
always really have a computer on every
desk that's a really strong goal it's a
power to the people kind of goal and it
really got them far as you can see um
and you should think about what you
really want um uh you know how you can
define a very strong goal and also you
know one that's a good business because
then you'll get tremendous
leverage um sort of related to this
point a lot of companies get started
purely to make money and they almost
always fail um if they don't fail they
generally don't change the world or they
don't become big companies and I'd argue
that the main reason is that um how much
money do you need so there's some people
in the world you know who want even
hundred billion dollars isn't enough
right and there's probably you know a
few people in the world like that and
they're they're going to be like that
but for most people probably you know
you know 1020 million doar maybe not
around here but most places would be
plenty of money right
um uh there's only so many things you
can buy right and so what happens is
companies get to the stage where they're
worth some amount of money and then they
get sold and then you know something bad
happens to them because the entrepreneur
no longer cares about it right and so
that tends to be a bad motivation for
companies which TR I sort of pushed on
the vision thing
um you also think I should think a lot
about how you want to treat employees I
wanted to uh give some examples my
father's father my grandfather was a
auto worker in Flint and during the sit
down strikes in Flint they actually
manufactured weapons so I have this
weapon they manufactur which is a like a
iron pipe like this line with a hunk of
lead about this pig on the end and he
would actually carry that to work every
day for protection from the company
basically um and this is two generations
ago right this isn't a long time ago uh
you know people you know Google don't
have to to do that hopefully um
uh but I think if you look at the trend
the trend is towards employees being
treated better and better because you
know basically in a company all you have
is employees right and um we try to push
that envelope rather than follow um so
we have a lot of benefits that are
unusual in our company like we have free
food that's uh well prepared um we have
like massas we have a Doctor Who's on
staff who's in the company um and you
know these things save employees a lot
of time I think ultimately they benefit
the company's bottom line and you they
make people more loyal and happier to
work and more efficient um so you just
think about you know I think that's a
really crucial issue um you also want to
have a lot of Integrity in what you do
because you want you know your employees
to have high integrity um you want to
have uh you want to trust like the
people you do business with and all
these things and in business that's
absolutely critical critical thing I
think um just over time you know that
even becomes more more strongly
reinforced to me uh because you need you
in business you need to trust people who
are working for you you need to trust
people who are doing business with you
and if you can't do that it just doesn't
work um I want to cover some things
about leadership style too
uh I think it's really useful to lead
through questions and actually um our
CEO actually really likes to talk about
this um uh but I realized s of from my
own family experience
that uh you know like I would call
actually my mother and ask her like when
I had difficult hiring decision remember
when we hired some of our first
employees I call her up and you know
should I hire this person and she'd ask
me a whole bunch of questions and I
decide whether I should hire them and I
think uh that's a great way to lead um
is just ask the right questions about
what's going on and get people motivated
uh to do the right things
um another point I make about big
companies is big companies generally
operate on trust so you have have people
you trust to do things and you know they
tell you what to do and you sort of okay
it or not if you're sort of in a
management position um I think at Google
we tend to be a little bit more
scientific and people are pretty smart
and so they you can present data like
you present data on your product like
how many people are using it how are
they using it how much money are you
making you present a whole bunch of data
to management and management looks at
the data and you discuss it you decide
what to do I think that's a better way
of doing things than just having you
know people you trust to do stuff and um
it helps if all the people in your
organization are broad enough or
interested enough that they can deal
with some of the details in the
organization um and that that data is
really useful in fact I'll show you some
I'll last slide I'll show you some data
from our internal company website we
have a tremendous amount of data
available to the company everyone in the
company and you know they can look at
how much money we made in the last five
minutes or they can look at um all sorts
of things things about the company that
normally you wouldn't have available and
we fight really hard to keep that
available to everyone in the company
because we think it's really important
for decision- making for people to feel
empowered and for them to have access to
what's going on that's a hard thing to
do um another thing I'd say is that the
structure and the culture of your
organization's really reflected in your
product so you should think about what
kind of product you want and then
structure the organization based on that
you know if you have two separate
organizations to do you know different
ad products
you'll end up with two different ad
products that you know don't operate at
all together right in fact that's what
we did um you can make decisions to do
that but the organizational structure
definitely comes out in your product and
I'll show you some things about culture
too I think that have come out for
us um I just wanted to flash this
because I thought it was kind of fun um
we had a lot of discussion about what
our core values should be and mainly I
want to highlight the last one um don't
be evil
uh this this actually came from one of
our early employees who was a Stanford
student actually too and um Amit he's
really a nice guy and he thought this
was a really important thing for us and
um it's quite something actually um it
turns out recently in the Press we were
compared to
anron and uh I guess somebody had told
the reporter we have this one of our
core values and the reporter had said
you know um you know that's what should
have been flashing on the screens at
Enron should have been like Google's
core values and like we were sort of the
good and Enron was evil um it's pretty
amazing when your company gets compared
to Enron in that way uh but I do think
this is an important thing I think we
are perceived as being a force sort of
for good in the world and our employees
feel that too and this is an important
thing to us um that's not true for a lot
of companies right uh and there's lots
of reasons for that uh but you know we
think we could sort of have a a uh a
interesting Market position on being
good instead of evil it's not very well
habitated by other companies um but it's
also more fun right so I don't know the
only other thing I I would tell you is
to think big is really important and
that uh that's an unusual thing you I'll
talk more about that
actually hiring is another thing I think
that really people don't focus on enough
actually when Eric came in he Ed Sergey
and I um who are the founders we go back
to reviewing every hire that happens in
the company so we started doing that
we're we've been doing that for like the
last uh eight months or so um you know
we personally look at every hire we may
talk to people um we look at the
compensation we look at you know we
spend a fair amount of time on that and
uh I think that's pretty important you
know you want to have hiring is a really
big deal and you want to have um pretty
tight control over it uh you see like at
least half your hiring come from inside
your company you're probably doing
something wrong especially at the early
stages but even now I think that's true
for Google we hire roughly half our
people from inside
referrals um and you want to check like
a whole bunch of things um uh you want
to sort of check whether they fit in the
culture whether they have like high
integrity whether they're really
motivated um communication skills even
in Engineers right which isn't commonly
done uh um being selling it related
activities is a pretty good predictor in
our our experience you know somebody has
run a marathon you know in really good
time they tend to be a good employee um
because they're just a really motivated
person they get really excited about
things they um they can execute um or
you know if they're a concert pianist or
you know whatever other kinds of things
they do that's usually a really positive
thing um smart productive initiative I
think the one that's most often ignored
is they asked sort of why not so there
there are lots of people who will tell
you you know no you can't do that and
there's few people who say you know why
can't we do
more and finding the people who you know
are going to ask you why can't we do
more are the kinds of people you want in
your company right uh because that will
get you
further so I want to make a point about
prototyping too so I think there's a
really big misconception about how to
start companies especially technology
companies um most successful internet
companies were prototyped by a handful
of people and I'll give you some
examples um actually a lot of them were
done as Hobbies Google kind of was done
as research eBay was done as a hobby
yahooo was done as a hobby um uh my
brother and some friends started egroups
which is a mailing list company that was
sold to Yahoo very successful that
actually was part of Scott's time for a
year he did it like part-time and it was
one computer that sat under a desk for
over a year and collected emails
and groups and things like that and they
had a party for this computer a year or
two ago because the computer I actually
bought the computer for them so I was
particularly involved in this but the
computer had handled over one billion
email messages this one computer and so
they put it up on a pedestal and they
actually had a party for the
[Applause]
computer you know Scott Scott did this
in his part in part time right and then
eventually we're like H this thing has
you know 10 million people using it
should be a
company um and it was still a computer
under a desk you know at that point and
Google was same kind of thing we
couldn't buy enough we couldn't get
enough computers at Stanford to support
the users we were getting and so we were
like wow we should really start a
company even though we're kind of
reluctant to um so you compare that sort
of during the do com boom you know the
way companies got started was you know
they raised 30 million they hired a
hundred people and then a year later
they might have a product and after
spending the $30 million right and a lot
of Internet things especially but a lot
of technology companies can be
prototyped very cheaply you know you can
get pretty far with a couple of people
in a garage and a little bit of money
which you know isn't hard to get right
um and so we had we actually bought the
initial discs for Google on three credit
cards and those were the first crawl
that we did as a company we used these
like our friends credit cards basically
to buy desks and that was enough to get
us going um
so I think uh the other thing I say is
that this helps in later stages too
because if you've done things cheaply
you'll continue to do them cheaply and
that's competitive Advantage
right um the other thing I noticed about
a lot of companies that are being
brought into the world now in the valley
is that they're often afraid to solve
the whole hard
problem
so uh if you're going to build you know
a company and you're only like one piece
of the puzzle it's pretty tough I mean
you can do it but you have to make a lot
of deals and they have to be the right
deals and there has to be enough people
there can't be monopolies or you're be
in trouble and uh you know it's fine to
pick a hard problem and solve the whole
thing uh I don't think this is done
enough uh because you really want to
control the whole user experience you
don't want to be reliant on some other
company to do a good job because they
probably won't right um it's unusual uh
to get good supplier relationships
especially when you're a really small
startup
right um and of course if you have a
single supplier consumer or a deal it's
pretty much a disaster because those
people will you know give you lots of
trouble
right I'd say don't settle in your early
stages no matter what you know the
quality of the people you start a
company with or your early investors are
critical to everything you do um and
people often get worried you know they
have this idea or they've been working
on something and they like oh how much
money will I have to give you know how
much Equity will I have to give to the
other Founders and you you shouldn't be
worried about that I remember this great
story um from Andy berstein who's one of
the sun uh Founders and is one of our
Angel Investors um when they were
starting Sun I forget who went to I
think venod went to Andy and said you
know I want you I want to start this
company and Andy said oh that's fine you
could take the technology for $50,000
and ven says no I want to pay you like
30% of the equity and I want you to work
in the
company and you know you see Sun did
pretty well right and ven doesn't regret
that I don't think um and I don't regret
like you know so I'm sharing my Equity
with Serge my co-founder I'm really
really happy to have him around and it's
been amazingly important and I feel you
know great about that and I feel great
about the equity we gave to our initial
investors um that's not to say you
should give a lot of equity to investors
um you should get a good deal of course
um especially with investors in fact
Andy like doubled our valuation we
asking for a particular valuation he
says no I think you guys should have
twice that valuation you know and
negotiating as an investor this is a
crazy thing right um so the point is if
you get the right investors things will
work out well um and you want to give
them enough equi so they're motivated to
help you that doesn't mean you give them
a lot but